foreign
is in Detroit Michigan hi Sarah welcome
to the Ramsay show
oh sure what's up
my father-in-law bought a home for my
husband's ex-wife to live in
about 15 years ago
stop stop stop stop stop stop stop this
sounds a hillbilly already I'm having
trouble what what in the world
bought your husband's ex-wife a house to
live in
yes and a moonshine still out back
you know I don't understand the
situation at all my family doesn't do
things like this no normal people don't
do crap like this
it usually is the other way around I
mean you know Byron oh my goodness okay
so he after the divorce maybe he's
taking care of the kids maybe that's it
was his grandkids
okay but still stupid but okay
at the time they had two teenagers and
um I think that I think he uh one was
about 10 years old
so this was about 15 years ago so she's
lived there since then
um she doesn't pay rent father-in-law
has upkeep the home and well the house
is not in her name he bought it and lets
her live there
yes and kept the house in his name okay
good okay that's better even okay
is it yeah this is going to be a
supernova I can't wait this is gonna be
great
so
um the kids are grown now she still
lives there and I just happened to see a
piece of paper
that said
um title on death the title to go over
to my husband when my father-in-law
passes away
so I guess my father-in-law is expecting
my husband to keep the house up and no
um I don't care what it expects no
as my wife told me once John I'm not
doing chores for you after you're dead
okay so here's the thing uh regardless
of how it occurred where it is today is
stupidville can we agree with that
yeah so your that your husband needs to
go sit down have a cup of coffee with
his dad and say Dad uh I don't want to
have to deal with this crap you need to
deal with it now
uh ex-wife doesn't have a reason to live
there anymore free the kids are grown
and gone she needs to move on now
not mean it's weird
it's weird just say it out loud it's
lived rent free for 15 years he did it
because he's a Grandpa's heart I got it
I got a Grandpa's heart right and
Grandpa's heart sometimes because you do
stupid butt things and he did a stupid
butt thing but he needs to handle this
before he dies
what yeah okay so I don't even know I
can hear in your voice he's not going to
so your is your husband a wuss when it
comes to his dad
a little bit no Dave of course he is he
bought his ex-wife a house of course
yeah okay so here you really you need to
give your run down to Walmart and pick
your husband up a backbone they're on
all three and you need to send him on
over to his dad and say Dad I don't want
this house unless you move her out
before you die
because I don't want to have to deal
with her she's my ex for a reason
we don't want the house take my name off
the deed or get her out one of the two
because I'm not going to have to deal
with evicting my ex-wife because the day
right the day you inherit this she gets
evicted
if she doesn't move voluntarily
right which I don't think she was is he
a free ride that comes to an end to my
girl time to move and when Dave starts
talking French you know he's serious
that's hillbilly French right there oh
yeah redneck that's just not this is
dumb go ahead Sarah
would it be an option for him to instead
just feed the house over to the ex-wife
since he wanted to if he wants to give
it to her he can give it to her I don't
care this is a weird freaking family
okay but I if I'm in your shoes I want
to tell you what I'm trying to do with
all my sarcasm and bombasticness is you
think this is crazy and you're right
that's what I'm trying to do is affirm
you your feelings about this are
completely correct this is strangeville
stupidville weirdville okay let me let
me affirm one more three there are three
towns right together and they
intersection is your ex his ex-wife's
house okay
Sarah there's 22 million people listen
to this going oh my God there's another
layer to this
also
you're realizing in real time your
husband is uh like Dave Dave eloquently
said doesn't have a backbone and hasn't
dealt with something that should have
been dealt with a long long time ago and
it's right for you to also feel that
sense of who who is this guy when things
get sideways he just goes oh so it's
gonna be okay this is XY this is
somebody that's out of his life they
went through a legal process
so you're right to call him on that as
well
you'll need to have that conversation
because you're losing respect for him
right
here's the thing he's going to deal with
it or he's going to deal with it or he's
going to deal with you
he's going to deal with it with his dad
he's going to deal with evicting her
after he gets the house or he's going to
deal with you he gets to deal with this
it's not an option
he just gets to choose what he deals
with
and the easiest path is go sit down have
a cup of coffee with his nutty father
right and go Dad no I don't want this
house no I don't want your timeshare
either don't leave me that either both
of them are dumb right I don't want this
and if Dad won't deal with it then you
two need to decide
um are we gonna go through illegal
proceeding and evict her and sell this
house and she's gonna sue us and all
that or are we gonna deed the house over
to her and swap no no I'm not giving it
to her there's no way there's no way she
just needs to leave this is this woman
has had I've had enough of this woman
already this new this woman needs to
move out of this house okay my God what
a freeloader and so no okay I was
feeling guilty no you don't need to feel
guilty this is dumber than a rock
so here's what okay here's the steps if
it's me you need to sit down with your
husband and the two of you need to
address the fact that he won't address
this John's right because this is going
to put a splinter in your own
relationship you don't want to leave
there number two then he needs to go
really he does need to go sit down talk
to his dad very calmly nicely he doesn't
have to be as crazy as I'm being on the
air I'm doing that to give you strength
and remind you that you're normal and
that what you're thinking is real
because the voices I just gave were also
in your head so I'm just I'm just saying
them out in the loud okay now he sits
down with his dad calmly and says Dad
this is weird I don't have to deal with
this I don't want to deal with her
that's why she's my ex and you need to
move her out of there before you die or
you need to take my name off of this
whole thing if Dad won't deal with it
and he leaves him the thing that instant
dad is ill your husband needs to tell
his ex-wife she has 30 days and we're
going to be selling the house you've got
to move
and your husband needs to handle this
none of this are you responsible for he
has to man up
and handle this it's his freaking family
and his freaking mess and he's got to do
it and you're gonna kick him hard enough
to get him to do it this is the Ramsey
Show